our Kent newmeyer in your book you quote
someone saying that Thomas Jefferson had
an unrelenting mutual hatred or there
was an unrelenting mutual hatred between
Thomas Jefferson and John Marshall yes
unrelenting mutual hatred I believe it
was on tree landing and it was you might
say a very costly hatred the certainly a
central theme of Marshalls life was this
conflict between he and Jefferson but of
course it wasn't just personal it was
ideological and I think it encompasses
some of the great themes of Marshalls
jurisprudence that is to say Jefferson
as a representative of local culture
states rights Marshall the
representative of nationalism and that I
think truly is the great theme of
Antebellum history but in addition to
the ideological disagreements between
these two great men there was a personal
animosity there which I mean as a
biographer it was it was interesting to
discover but I would say it wasn't real
ending and I think also was probably
mutual
I mean Marshall was not a great hater
but I really think he had if not hatred
then certainly contempt for his second
cousin and Piedmont neighbor so yeah it
turns out to be one of the major themes
of my book if there is an interpretive
theme it's probably the states rights
nationalism as symbolized by by these
two men and of course it's it's one of
the great ironic twists of history that
one of them should have been Chief
Justice of the United States and the
other should have been President of the
United States and so what turned what
might have been a personal hatred among
Virginians turns out to be a
institutionally significant I guess you
might say if John Marshall were alive
and saw what happened in the election of
2000 and the court what would his
reaction be Brian knew you were gonna
ask me that question which means I might
we should have something a profoundly
intelligent to say you know what's
really difficult to to
imagine what the difference would have
been of course there was a disputed
election you might recall in 1800 but
between Jefferson and burr both of these
guys got 73 votes in the electoral
college and this was before the 12th
amendment you recall so it had to go to
the House of Representatives everybody
knew that Jefferson you know what was
understood to be you know the next
president United States Byrd not
withdraw the race however which prompted
all sorts of machinations especially
among the Federalists who thought they
might make a deal with Burr and maybe
get a little more out of birth and they
might out of Jefferson and since they
controlled the house you know it was
possible for them really to shape the
course of history
Marshall was not in the house at this
particular time although you know he
wasn't in Congress in in 1799
congressman from Virginia but he did
look on the election with a guess you
might say a very sad eyes as a matter of
fact there's there's some marvelous
letters between Marshall and Hamilton
Hamilton of course hated both of these
guys but he thought probably Jefferson
would be the lesser of the two evils and
Hamilton who Marshall greatly respected
was very subtly kind of suggesting to
Marshall that maybe whatever support he
had he might throw to Jefferson Marshall
wrote this letter back which was very
revealing that he admitted that he
didn't know much about a burr but was
probably not quite true because
everybody knew something about it or
bearer but he knew enough about
Jefferson to think that Jefferson's
presidency would be an absolute disaster
I mean it was his foreign policy and it
was Marshalls distinct feeling I think
probably maybe a wrong feeling as it
turned out that that that Jefferson was
going to dissipate the authority of the
presidency and the authority of the
national government and in a sense
weaken the Constitution but what about
the impact that John Marshall had on the
court itself and what the court had been
able to do what it did in in 2000 if he
hadn't done what he did back in 1801 for
34 years
no clear clearly not I mean the the the
court in in two thousand of course is a
magnificent institution it's ensconced
in this beautiful marble palace it has
accumulated great Authority although
it's always had its critics great I
guess you might say capital with the
American people and I can't read the
minds of those people who who voted the
judges the justices who decided Bush v
Gore but if some scholars are right and
I think they probably are the majority
decided that it would be in the interest
of the nation to settle this not gonna
let it go on not to let it drag on they
must have known that they would be using
up a little bit of the capital that John
Marshall himself helped build had the
issue been presented say in the disputed
election of 1800 it would have been an
entirely different scene because there
was no kept the court had no capital it
had no reputation as a matter of fact it
was a when Marshall took over the court
in eighteen one the institution was
pretty much on the ropes one of the one
of the former Chief Justice's John J
actually John Adams asked John J to
return to the chief justice ship before
he gave the job to to Marshall and J
turned him down for a number of reasons
but one of the reasons was J's
conviction that the court was destined
to be a the weakest of the branches of
government and perhaps it would even
give way to the to the other political
branches so Marshall one of the great
things I think of his chief justice ship
was to separate long politics somehow or
other the idea that Marshall would have
ventured forth politically in what would
be in a clear political decision settled
the disputed election of 1800 in favor
of of somebody or other I can't imagine
who would be probably burr
since the hatred of Jefferson among the
Federalists was strong it would have
been a disaster but but Marshall great
strategist I think that he was
and political realist that he was would
have never done that what he would have
done if you could imagine Marshall being
somehow there placed on the court in the
year 2000 given his disposition and so
on I mean it's one of those questions
that I think would be impossible to
answer but I know I'm pretty sure I know
what he would have done if the issue
somehow there would have presented
itself in in 1800 there been 16 chief
justices in the history of the United
States what number was John Marshall
well he was number four although a lot
of people say that he was really number
one I mean the two main chief justices
from the 1790s were John Jay and
Ellsworth but but the court of course in
the 1790s was a much different
institution it's very difficult to I
think for us to get back into that
institution-building age I mean they
were simply almost everything was what's
up for grabs I mean of course the court
got a marvelous grant of jurisdiction
and it got what you might say equal
billing in the Constitution after all it
got an article right Congress gets an
article the executive gets an article
the court gets article three and if you
read article three I mean it grants the
court jurisdiction over cases which are
bound to be of great importance I mean
providing the court can you might say
get its act together institutionally but
it was not all that clear that the court
would ever manage to do that I guess
what I'm arguing is that the outline of
judicial review at least in my opinion
was to be found in the wording and you
might say the architecture of the
Constitution what is a judicial review
mean well judicial review is the power
of the Supreme Court to declare an act
of Congress unconstitutional acts of
States unconstitutional reversed
decisions of state courts if they are in
violation of a federal law or the
Constitution you know I try to tell my
students when I when I teach this stuff
that you really have to
article 3 of the Constitution which
gives powers to the court with the
famous article 6 and what article 6 of
the constant Constitution does actually
it's very simple I mean it makes the
Constitution the federal laws and
treaties made under the authority of the
Constitution the supreme law of the land
in other words the Constitution is above
every other law including acts of
Congress including acts of state
legislatures including decisions of
state courts and if you look at that if
you look at the jurisdiction the powers
granted the federal courts in the
Supreme Court it's entirely possible
that clients are parties to two cases
claiming under the Constitution will
confront parties to a case claiming
under for example state law and what
basically Marshall said in Marbury I
mean it's it's a it's a marvelously
simple statement you know actually he
stole the line from Blackstone Stan
through construction but what he said if
you've got two conflicting acts and one
is supreme over the other one has to
give way and judicial review of course
is is this process by which the court
says which will give way and if there's
a conflict the Constitution or federal
statute law in the case of States or
federal treaties in the case of States
will win out but you know it's I guess I
need to make clear at least as I see it
that judicial review is not just saying
yes or no to requests of power but it's
it's the reason justification for the
courts say striking down an act of
Congress as in violation of the
Constitution and you know that there are
precedents for judicial review before a
marshal before Marbury
but what Marshall did it seems to me was
to give the reason justification in
magnificent statesmen like language that
was remarkably clear persuasive at times
quite eloquent and quotable and I think
this was all this was all the difference
in other words the various things in the
Constitution the earlier State Court
decisions
props lent themselves towards some sort
of judicial review theory of the
Federalist Party which talked about
judicial review after all Hamilton's
Federalist number 78 talked about it
openly the Brutus letters by Yeats of
New York talked about judicial review
this long before Marshall what he did is
pull all these various strands together
in Marbury and of course make it stick
where do you teach law well I'm I I
shouldn't mention I taught history for
many years at the University of
Connecticut and then retired from
teaching history and began teaching at
the law school University of Connecticut
law school which is in Hartford so I
actually have a lovely position up there
I teach only a seminar each semester but
I have I have marvelous students good
colleagues and I think I've ever had so
much fun in my life to tell the honest
truth so um and it's you know it's
difficult to teach constitutional
history to undergraduates
sad to say it really is I mean you have
to sort of start from square zero at the
law school if you get you know some
third-year students which I frequently
do they're you know very good people
they've already they had the language so
it I mean I'm probably learning as much
as they are to tell you the honest truth
but how how long have you been to
university well I came in 1960 the
University of Connecticut and it-it's my
first real job where'd you come from
well I I got I came from I'm a Nebraskan
so I went the University of Nebraska and
as an undergraduate I suppose my career
you might say started in this little
tiny College called dawn College in
Crete Nebraska where alright I had maybe
I think maybe I mentioned it in the book
but this guy Kenneth rossmann was the
best teacher I've ever seen I've never
seen a better teacher than he was and so
I started out to be a basketball coach
and rossmann sort of inspired me to
think of history and it was sort of a
serendipitous thing I could be coaching
basketball in wahoo who knows can you
remember the first time you got really
interested in John Marshall as a person
or as a historical figure well
actually I I guess it when I made up my
mind I wanted to teach Constitutional
History I mean if you could have teach
constitutional history sooner or later
have to confront John Marshall I mean he
is he's the big man and I I think I
encountered Marshall first of all
through Albert beverages biography and
beverage was the great I think the first
great biographer of marshal has his four
volumes came out in I think 1916 1918
and it was it was very worshipful
biography but it was also a very richly
textured extremely vivid I think you
might say even passionate biography a
beverage you know was the senator you
know from Indiana and he identified for
various reasons with with Marshall as he
did it with Lincoln as a matter of fact
the connection between Marshall and
Lincoln is an absolutely fascinating one
that beverage so but anyhow I I think
that I first really got acquainted with
Marshall by by reading beverage and our
beverage was a two-term senator from
Indiana who wrote the four volumes on
John Marshall and a couple of volumes on
Abraham Lincoln yes it was he by the way
I constantly see references to him and
I've never read him does he is he a good
writer oh yes yes I think so I mean he
right when he was the senator before
oh this was afterwards he got if I
remember correctly he got defeated I
believe it was in the 1912 election and
after having got defeated I mean in in
some ways beverage got defeated by the
same democratic political democratic
forces that Marshall hated cmart
Marshall was a to some extent this
matter of fact the whole tradition of
judicial review was fashioned as a
response to the rise of political
parties and political democracy and so
when beverage got wiped out you might
say by party manipulations and and
popular vote and so on he sort of turned
well he did turn full time to the
biography and he put his whole heart and
you know was his whole vision of
America which he felt by the way was it
was sort of under siege in the early
20th century he found in Marshall the
embodiment of all of those values that
he felt were in jeopardy I think in the
early 20th century and so therefore his
writing first of all it's as I said it's
very worshipful I mean it's that that's
the real deficiency of it I think it it
is not what we would call a critical or
balanced biography but the virtue of
that kind of writing of course is that
it resonates you know it Minh has a kind
of fire that you don't see in most
modern biographies that you well maybe
that's wrong but certainly that's the
key and you know the other thing about
beverage he was a voracious researcher
and he did all this research in days
before there were you know the National
Union catalog of manuscripts before you
could you know do online research or
before you had easy access to to
depositories he did all this stuff and
he consulted the Marshall papers in the
Marshall papers by the way it's a very
real reflection of Marshall himself
unlike the Adams is unlike Jefferson
unlike the other founding fathers
Marshall just didn't seem to care that
much about preserving his papers yeah
yeah it was gonna say if you have to do
research it's very difficult because
there's no there was no collection of
papers in one place yes he died at age
79 and 1835 in your book but where was
he born okay he was born in on the
frontier of Virginia in in Fauquier
County Virginia and his how far is that
from Washington DC well it's a couple
hours it's it's a beautiful part of the
country I mean about that whole area is
is you know west of Washington DC for a
couple hours we'll get you into what you
might say marshal country what's in and
around Warrington and so on I think is a
is the place and I think Marsha mark you
know I've never visited that what's left
of Marshalls birthplace at Oak Hill but
I think it's gone into private ownership
of a not mistaken but was it Oak Hill
Virginia was that the name of this state
no that was if that was the name of the
place that was the family place I mean
it was not a town there was no well
Germantown I think was perhaps at that
time the you know designation for that
place but it was you know when when the
Marshall family moved there in the 1750s
there was really nothing there I mean
there was I mean it was really truly
frontier where did they come from why do
they came from Westmoreland and you know
was his father I think in Marshall's
words was a planter of narrow means
which meant that he had a few slaves a
large ambition he was obviously not born
to the purple
although Marshall was descended on his
mother's side from the Randolph's and of
course that made him a part of the you
know it seems at times that almost
everybody in Virginia has descended from
the Randolph's but I mean it was a mark
of distinction how did he related to
Thomas Jefferson how's that second that
was a second cousin well they were both
descended from the Randolph's I mean
that was the that was the that was the
connection you know it's funny uh
revealing I'm not sure funny but
Marshall never spoke of his family
pedigree I'm sure he you know he must
have thought of it but it it was it was
not something that was on his mind he he
was forward-looking he really didn't
look back and I think it was that that
forward-looking quality maybe nurtured
on the frontier which made him I assume
as remarkably sort of American but much
more so than than v4 some of the other
founding fathers he is a recognizable
person to me I mean he's the kind of guy
you could go out and and feel
comfortable having a beer with or his
favorite drink was mint mint julep and
you could have had a good time
you couldn't have it wouldn't have been
that easy with Washington
certainly not with Jefferson maybe John
Adams I but but Marshall picked up some
of the frontier democracy from the
frontier so here's the guy he ends up
being a federalist a conservative that
personally he has all these remarkable
Democratic egalitarian qualities and it
was really that combination I think
which which almost was the key to his
ability as chief justice he was very
egalitarian very sensitive to other
people didn't stand on prerogatives
didn't stand on family he said he was
tall sinewy thick head of hair
socializer non-judgmental devoid of
malice there are other except maybe with
Thomas Jefferson I think he had a little
a little tinge of malice that he
reserved for Jefferson but yes he yeah
easy conviviality casual summer manor
and frontier accent how do you find all
this out who do you rely on to tell you
that well you know the quote about the
accident comes from from John Randolph
of Roanoke who you know was another one
of the Randolph's by the way but who was
very interested in family very
interested in Tidewater aristocracy and
very interested in sort of Englishness
and when he heard Marshall speak for the
first time there was detectable I think
twang was the word that Randolph Houston
I mean Randolph referred to it sort of
lovingly but it was it wasn't sort of
evidence I think that Marshall wasn't
quite of the you know the real first
line families not quite to the
aristocratic thing that that Randolph
admired so much Hollow
Randolph became close friends with
Marshall and Marshall with Randolph
remarkable because these guys were miles
apart ideologically and Randolph wasn't
was really one of the most the sort of
romantic states rights anti-national and
a very real critic of the Marshall Court
but he loved John Marshall you could
Albert Beveridge is saying that the one
conception that Marshall had was
American nationalism it was it was it
was the design I think in the tapestry
the fabric of his life I think every
every biographer has just discovered
this to be true well explained though I
mean so that we can delineate usually in
him and somebody else like Thomas
Jefferson believed in what the states
should have all the power
and then this guy believed that it
should be a national well let me let me
go back because I think you'd have to
say honestly that that Jefferson truly
was I mean he loved the nation in the
states rights people you know from
Jefferson to Calhoun and so on uh they
were they were there when the nation was
created during the Revolution and so the
idea of being an American was did not
belong exclusively to any party both the
Federalists of the party of John
Marshall and the Jeffersonian
Republicans the party really was
Jefferson founded he in Madison they
both were patriotic they both cherished
the revolution as the moment of
conception for this great nation what
they what they disagreed on of course is
what the nation was going to look like
ah and it was at this point I think that
the the term nationalism and states
rights becomes at least constitutionally
speaking much more meaningful because
Jefferson John Randolph you know John C
Calhoun
were committed to a nation which was
made up of States and that the states
you have one has to remember at this
time the the state government was the
government that really touched people
state and local government was what
counted I mean the reach of the national
government was it was so flimsy at this
time it almost didn't exist and people
like Jefferson felt that the modicum of
power over
the national government had was too much
and and of course this is this is the
basis I think of the personal and
ideological antagonism when did that
start when did they know each other well
you know of course they knew each other
from you know the 1780s and 1790s where
the hatred started is is I've tried to
figure this out I sometimes think it was
a chemical discipline it between these
two guys
I mean is there such a thing as a
common-law personality yeah a cop by
that I mean you know the lawyer who
practiced the common law who went to the
court every day represented people of
all different developed they kind of
down-home down-to-earth non theoretical
gradualist approach Jefferson on the
other hand tended to think he would he
at least Marshall perceived him as a
sort of visionary or a metaphysician or
a speculator the grand themes of the
Declaration of Independence for example
and so we're we're did they actually
where do these things actually begin to
collide these two different visions of
America the localist thing as Jefferson
saw at the states rights thing and
Marshalls vision of nationalism by the
way and the national vision of course
had had an economic dimension to it I
mean I think Marshall innocence was a
Hamiltonian to the extent that he saw
the growth and I argue that in the book
he not only saw the growth of a
expanding market but he saw the the
national economic unit as maybe being
the real foundation of American
nationalism
so if he could use the court to enhance
you know trade commerce across state
lines
he felt that maybe those economic sinews
would bind the nation together would
overcome this sort of localism which
jefferson saw and of course i think hey
we're talking really about
the roots of the civil war go back
before you do that to a John Marshall
the person born in Fauquier County 1755
1755 how long did he live there well he
lived there really until he moved to
Richmond and and in the 1780s when he
became a lawyer in 1780 and I need to
practice a little bit in Fauquier County
but he his Polly the Ambler who whom he
married jacqueline Ambler was the
treasurer of the colony and then the
state of Virginia and so when the
ambulance moved to Richmond Marshall was
deeply in love he moved to Richmond and
of course by that time he was a lawyer
and Richmond was the center of the the
legal community that's where the action
was in Richmond how long did he serve in
the military six years where well he he
began as a it he signed up in in the
summer of 1775 and the Culpeper militia
so he belonged to one of the numerous
militia units which which sprang up and
he was one of the first to sign up and
of course his father organized a
regiment Thomas Marshall and in in a
sense I think it was the father's
influence of course which helped spur
Marshalls
you know patriotism his his early
decision to join the military so he
fought in a number of battles I think
the first battle he fought as a member
of the Culpeper militia was a what we
call the Battle of Great Bridge down and
around Norfolk and what's war we're
talking about the American Revolution so
he did fight in the revolution yes and
then he fought at the germantown
monmouth courthouse how old was he then
well he Williams 19 years old when when
he joined up had he had he studied the
law yet well actually his father in 1772
was one of the first to subscribe to
Blackstone's commentaries
what's that Blackstone Sir William
Blackstone was a Tory lawyer who who
gave a series of law lectures at Oxford
and these were published in four volumes
of four thick volumes of the compound on
you know commentaries on the laws of
England and Marshall and actually every
other lawyer in America really if there
was one book they read and many of them
only read one but it was Blackstone's
commentaries and so Marshalls father put
a copy of Blackstone commentaries in in
his son's hands in 1778 so this was long
before the Revolution and so the the
great irony is that Marshall learned a
lot of his law from a Tory lawyer I mean
I mean from his father or from well know
from from Blackstone oh I'm sorry yeah
yeah no his dad was yes that was it was
a planner he was not highly educated but
his father believed in education and so
in a sense he was very much interested
in seeing that his son but he I think he
marked his son for the career in law yes
was his father when you mentioned torres
where i got his father born here over
and no he was he was born in this
country in this country anna was his
father born i believe so yes I think
they I'm not sure to tell you the truth
about the exact pedigree right at the
moment here but that there's been all
sorts of efforts to to trace Marshall
back to the 17th century England and so
on and establish a kind of aristocratic
lineage I'm not sure to tell you the
truth and how that holds up but his
father was was born in this country
Westmoreland County Virginia yes when
did he when did John Marshall study
under George Wythe for three months in
1780 and Marshall actually was
technically still on the army but he was
on leave and as a matter of fact he
didn't really see much action after 1780
but so his his father I think was
stationed at Yorktown and Marshall came
home to visit and decided to to attend
with lectures in the in December 1780
which which he did and of course his
girlfriend Polly
was in Yorktown at that time so there
there was a secondary reason in a sense
for attending he was there wait a min
Mary that when he when he was in William
and Mary and that's that's where with of
course and with it just been appointed
he with the course had the first law
lectureship in this country at William
and Mary so Marshall was one of his very
first students and we do have the
account book that is to say Marshalls
notes which he took when he was
attending Lewis lectures it was George
with poet well George with was I suppose
one is surely one of the great legal
scholars of late 18th century of
Virginia he later became Chancellor of
court of equity that is to say of
Virginia but and he was a lawyer and you
know he was one of these polymaths even
he was a statesman a lawyer perhaps of
this kind of gentleman could only be
produced in late 18th century Virginia
but with what was a very learned man and
dedicated to teaching and the number of
people that he influenced including
Marshall was quite quite amazing
including Jefferson Madison and so on it
was it was quite amazing but also the
Virginia one of the Virginia
representatives at the Constitutional
Convention yes of which Marshall was not
and nor was Thomas Jefferson Jefferson
wasn't at the either the ratifying
convention or the Philadelphia
Convention with I'm not sure was whether
with was at the ratifying convention in
June of 1788 I don't think you what he
had gone to Philadelphia but did not
sign no I got to leave early no are you
sure about that I can't say that for
sure to tell you the truth I didn't
think he was that at the Philadelphia
Convention but he certainly had a huge
impact on Marshall and many other people
even in that you know three months
period yes you say that John Marshall
was an Episcopal but did not take
communion what did that mean Miska
Parian well I mean he I think he didn't
take communion
on the basis of principle he probably
simply did not believe but but he was
deeply religious person one of the
things that struck me one of the last
things he said in his letters I mean he
was he wrote this letter to his grandson
about the you know the importance of a
clean conscience and a composure which
comes from knowing that you've done your
best and it was Marshalls a feeling that
religion was the source of this kind of
this kind of virtue which he found so
necessary so he supported the church and
was was one of the reliable supporters
of the church in in Richmond but
apparently he never mean Chuck Hopson
the editor of the Marshall papers told
me that I'm blaming this on shot but he
that Marshall never really took
communion I don't know that that's
established in any he never said any
reason why he didn't but it was a
principle decision I believe yeah how
did he become a friend of John Adams and
what jobs did John Adams appoint him to
well then Adams Marshall friendship of
course is the key the key ultimately as
you as you know to his appointment as as
chief justice and the initial
contributions I think came I mean first
of all let's go back for a second
because Marshall was the chief defender
of the Washington administration in
Virginia and of course John Adams was
vice president under Washington and so
the crucial decisions in that endless
war talking about the 1790s and
increasingly in Virginia even a great
man like George Washington was under
attack because Washington by Jefferson
Madison and the and the Virginia
Republicans looked came to look upon
Washington almost unbelievably has a
sort of traitor to the cause of course
because he was he was talking too much
nationalism the bank United States a pro
English foreign policy protective
tariffs all of these things
the states rights localist as they began
to take shape in 1790s felt were
anathema to their view of what the
nation should look like and it was
Marshall who stepped forth to defend
Washington's policies and especially his
foreign policy and especially the Jay
Treaty this was this was a kind of
watershed moment in early American
politics because Washington decided to
settle outstanding problems with Great
Britain in this treaty and of course by
the Jeffersonians and Virginia went nuts
because they felt that this was a
sellout to the former enemy and at the
expense of revolutionary France of
course which jefferson particularly felt
is should be our friend and and and so
on so marshall emerges as a defender of
federalism and so john adams your
question i mean adams when adams becomes
president marshall continues his his
affinity i think with with a federalist
party and his ability to to defend
Federalist principles and of course i
don't have solid proof for this but I'm
sure Washington conveyed to John Adams
his indebtedness to marshal I mean he
made it clear to marshal his
matter-of-fact Washington became a kind
of patron of marshal encouraged him to
run for Congress and so on so Marshall
emerges as the leading Federalist
politician even though he didn't like
political parties he was the most
effective Federalist in Virginia and so
it was during this period by the way
that that he begins to square off with
Jefferson who emerges in the 1790s as
the leader of the Jeffersonian
Republicans for John Marshall for days
as the Secretary of War for days and
then Secretary of State does that happen
well I mean it's a meteoric rise I guess
you might say what what I mean he didn't
do anything as Secretary of War and as a
matter of fact he didn't do an awful lot
that's memorable I think it was six
months as a secretary of state before he
became a chief justice
I mean he did of course I think support
Adams as moderate federalism
and this is an amazing thing Adams the
new biography by David McCullough and
other biographies have pointed out that
Adams had had he was fighting on two
fronts
one of course were the Jeffersonians who
held him in contempt the other were the
so called high Federalists in his own
party led by Hamilton & Hamilton's
cronies occupied key positions in in
Adams his cabinet which was a holdover
from the old Washington I mean it was a
great mistake Adams kept these guys on
Pickering and McHenry and so on and so
Hamilton in the last two years of the
1790s try to subvert Adams his
presidency and Marshall was a constant
support for Adams as moderate approach
and the crucial issue was Adams as a
decision not to declare war on France
after the failure of XYZ there was a
great rage in this country for a
declaration of war and of course the
Hamiltonians especially wanted war
against France I mean this this fit in
their pro-pro English commercial thing
and Hamilton wanted to be the head of
the army I mean he was an ambitious guy
i Adams a cook put the kibosh on this
and ended up finally firing these
Hamilton's spies in his cabinet and it
was Marshall really who defended Adams
all the way both his congressman and
both the Secretary of the state and it
was this I guess you might say a
stalwart service in the in the cause of
modern federalism I think that convinced
Adams finally that this guy had the
qualities that would make a great chief
but there's a period in history that
seems to be very important you walk over
the Supreme Court right now you'll see
this enormous statue of John Marshall
obviously they think he's important and
you point out in your book that he was
nominated by Adams by President Adams on
January the 20th 1801 before they you
know took the inauguration on January
the 20th as they do now and that he was
confirmed in in seven days as the Chief
Justice the United States and then in
the middle of all this
you have the William Marbury vs. Madison
case and that's all you know the
beginnings of the great case yeah the
whole process there and that was a very
few days so in order to do it we've got
him on the court he's chief justice he's
the fourth one as you say and then along
comes Marbury vs. Madison tell the story
about William Marbury and how that ended
up being one of the most important cases
that you write about well I think you'd
have to say that Marbury vs. Madison was
a case that was not born great I mean if
you looked at the factual environment
from which the case emerged I mean he
would have not predicted that this would
have been a great case it originated in
the Organic Act for the District of
Columbia which was an Act passed in the
last days of the John Adams
administration and we have to remember
that this is in the days before the 12th
amendment the defeated Congress came
back for a rump session in December and
so the Federalists are defeated at the
polls they come back for one more
go-around and they begin to pass all
these controversial acts one of the acts
was that was the Organic Act for the
District of Columbia which was one
actually one of the more innocuous of
the Federalist acts but it created 42
justices of the peace ship for the
District of Columbia I mean it stopped
you in a second to ask you a technical
question the Federalists john adams who
else i mean john has about to go out of
office so that they the world has
changed the whole election process
changed the world in in 1800 and and who
goes out besides john adams
well the the majority of the Federals in
both houses both house yes I mean it was
a Jeffersonian sweep in the election of
1800 so yeah the Federalists had not
only lost the presidency in the election
they lost both houses of Congress but
the but John Adams was nah man I mean
John Marshall was nominated and
confirmed by the Federalists the old
government yes and so he's the Chief
Justice yes right in next 34 years
that's right and
and of course he was put there not just
because as we suggested earlier because
of the services he had done Adams but
because Adams felt that here was a guy
who could turn the court into a bastion
of good sense against the radical
persuasions of this new party the
Jeffersonian Republicans so Marshall in
a sense was put in this this high office
with a sort of mandate and and judicial
review which emerges from the case of
Marbury becomes the first instance where
he might say he makes good on the
promise how many people are on the court
in 1801 there are six counting a chief
just who else is on there that we might
have heard of Samuel chase done on there
Samuel chase and William Paterson and
Bushrod Washington I think were the were
the key figures on the court it I think
you would have to say it it's
significantly to their work there was
not really a strong mind on the court
where did they physically meet well I
mean they didn't have the building over
here the the first I mean no they didn't
I mean I think it was in the basement
room of the north wing of the Capitol it
was a very modest Chamber's indeed very
cramped as a matter of fact the the
justices had to robe and disrobe but in
public there was no conference room I
mean it was I I think I've often thought
that Jefferson would have been pleased
with the architectural arrangement
because that's exactly where he wanted
the court is someplace in the basement
of American government and of course it
is right in Jefferson that his old enemy
Marshall because they were enemies by
this time ideological enemies and and I
think there was the personal animosity
there too so the stage is set for a
shootout I guess you might say you
remember whether the presidency had been
determined by the early part of January
or not or the gore January of 20th and
Thomas Jefferson absolutely been
determined by that time you know I I'm
not sure that there were as you know
they the votes went on I think there
were 36 votes in the House of
Representatives before they finally
because disputed elections went to the
House of Representatives at that time
and it was it was clear yeah it was
clear that Jefferson was gonna be
president by the end by that time yeah
John abs is gonna go out on march the
force so he's got this little time
period in here yeah to these forty to
justice of the pieces yes instances of
the piece yeah William Marbury yeah
let's go back to him and William Marbury
was one of these guys so what happens I
mean these are these folks not
surprising we are all Federalists and so
the Commission's to the justices of the
peace are you might say signed sealed
but but not delivered physically not
physically delivered but the president
had signed them I mean it was complete a
deal except that they hadn't really been
delivered and so when James Madison
who's Secretary of State takes over
March 5th he finds on his desk forty-two
justices of the peace commissions to be
delivered of course all two Federalists
and basically what what what what
Jefferson said is you know this is
outrageous by the way this this flagrant
patronage move was one of the things
which which separated Jefferson and
Adams
I mean Jefferson felt that this was a
real betrayal so I mean it was the
refusal to deliver those Commission's
that that was the factual background
from our great verses Madison and Willie
Marbury was in four other guys were I
brought a case they took it under
so-called original jurisdiction directly
the Supreme Court United States and
asked Marshall and the court to issue
what we call a writ of mandamus to the
secretary of state showing cost why
shouldn't delivery it's the writ of
mandamus writ of mandamus is an ancient
sort of common law what we call it
Caraga tear it it's basically an order
which issues from a Superior Court to
inferior courts and to officials of
government ordering them to do something
the ordering James Madison deliver the
Commission yeah and so so Charles the
Union which is
William R Barry's lawyer asks the court
for this pure Agata writ send this order
to Madison telling to to deliver these
commissions because hey they looked at
it as a piece of property it was a
fasted right at least that was that was
William R Barry's take on it by the way
where's James Marshall in all this
James Markham Marshall was was was
Marshalls brother and he plays a strange
it is sort of a somewhat mysterious role
in all this he had been appointed
another one of the last-minute acts of
the Adams administration was the
Judiciary Act of 1801 which altered the
whole structure of the federal courts
what it did was to to relieve the the
Supreme Court United States of the
obligation to ride circuit because these
early justices were trial judges they
were only in Washington really you know
at the most a month and a half during
this period the rest of the time they
rode circuit where they set with the
federal district judges in the various
states it was it was a tremendous burden
and there was a lot of opposition among
the justices to this this onerous thing
so the Judiciary Act of 1801 did away
with circuit writings created a whole
bunch of of new circuit courts and 16
new circuit judges John Marshall's
brother was one of these Federalist
appointees he was now a circuit court
justice
now of course remember that one of the
first things that the Jeffersonians did
was to repeal the judicial Act of 1801
and so all of these new circuit judges
were eliminated without really having
taken office so I mean that's part of
the political environment but James
Markham marshal figures in Marbury
because he's he's called to sign an
affidavit testifying to the existence of
these mysterious commissions and when
the case finally makes its appearance in
the Supreme Court you know Charles Lee
brings the case they're the preliminary
arguments are made in 18 1
Jefferson doesn't allow any lawyers to
appear he as a matter of fact it's his
way of repudiating turning his back
stonewalling if you will the Marshall
Court because you get by the way could
you get away with that today no no no
you couldn't
well I mean you can I suppose a party I
can't imagine party going to the trouble
of getting a case to the Supreme Court
and then not arguing it but the argument
in the great case of Marbury was ex
parte it was it was from one side only
only William Marbury Charles Lee's was
his lawyer only Charles Lee argues the
case and all through this case Jefferson
refuses to cooperate
I mean Jefferson of course Madison you
know it is the defendant Marbury vs.
Madison but but but Jefferson is clearly
pulling the strings in the background he
will not allow people in the Department
of State to testify to the existence of
these disputed commissions so Marshall
is is faced with a powder you get the
existence of these commissions on the
courts records so he calls on his
brother who testifies to the fact that
he showed up and actually saw those
commissions as a matter of fact took a
couple of him because he wanted to
deputize some marshals and so you have
this written affidavit from Marshalls
brother in the case testifying to the
existence of these commissions the
purpose of all this all these
shenanigans is to circumvent the
stonewalling tactics of Thomas Jefferson
and get the existence of the disputed
Commission's on the record so the court
could decide it and this was all going
on in 1801 the case was decided of
course in 1830 how could you wait that
long to decide that well actually
Marshall had no choice because when they
when the Jeffersonians repealed the
Judiciary Act of 1801 they essentially
it's a complicated thing and I won't
bore you with it but the impact of the
repeal Act of 18 to was to it was to
adjourn the court for 14 months so there
was a period between the term of 18 1
and 18 3 when the court
you know didn't hold its sessions in
Washington when he met when the Supreme
Court made the decision in 1803 on
Marbury vs. Madison what was the vote
well it was a unanimous decision six
zero Christopher they all Federalists by
the way although the justices yes they
were
and of course it's amazing because
something happens it in that decision
which is probably more important than
the decision itself in the great sweep
of things the court abandoned Surrey
what we call Surrey autumn opinions in
the 1790s the justices all wrote
separate opinions this was the English
practice this was the practice in the
colonial and state courts one of the
first things Marshall introduced was the
concept of a majority opinion in other
words a single opinion speaking for the
whole court written by one justice and
that justice in the early period was
usually Marshall and that was the case
in Marbury vs. Madison so it's a
significant case not only be just
because it declared an act of Congress
unconstitutional and came up with a
recent justification why this was
constitutional but it was an opinion
written by a single judge Marshall for
the whole court and it was that
combination that a majority opinion a
forceful majority opinion and of course
declaring the judicial did William
Marbury ever become justice of the peace
no why not
I don't know whether he gave up the
quest or what I could he have after the
decision was made well no no I mean the
the decision went against him you recall
I mean Marshall finally said that the
first of all there were there were these
famous three questions yes a Marbury was
entitled to his decision and according
to the rule of law in this country
and this was a long lecture which
Marshall managed to give in the opinion
against Thomas Jefferson even the
president United States is not above the
law to withhold this commission violated
as a matter of fact a federal statute
Marshall gives this huge long lecture
and it looks like he's digging himself a
huge hole backing himself into the
corner but then as as you as you know he
finally says I'm sorry but the court
can't help you the court can't issue a
writ of mandamus ordering Madison to
deliver these Commission's because the
authority to that was rested on section
13 of the Judiciary Act of 1789 which is
a federal statute and that Act Marshall
said gave original juror pretended to
give original jurisdiction to the
Supreme Court United States and when
Congress attempted to bestow original
jurisdiction to the Supreme Court it
violated article 3 of the Constitution
why because article 3 of the
Constitution talks about original
jurisdiction the notion being that
original jurisdiction is not within the
purview of Congress to change so
Marshall declares section 13 of the
Judiciary Act unconstitutional so
Marbury doesn't get his Commission's but
the court and Marshall get an occasion
to explain why it is the court had the
power to declare section 13
unconstitutional and we're about out of
time so but that decision did what to
the future of the relationship of the
court to the this town the other the
legislative branch and the president's
you know funny because of course this is
the great decision maybe the most famous
of all decisions
but there was not a great deal of hoopla
about it in eighteen three perhaps some
you know Jefferson didn't realize that
said Marshall had stolen the family farm
it's only really a bee I mean it was it
was a fairly narrow decision I mean
Marshall justified judicial review but
he didn't say that that Congress had to
obey he didn't say the court had the
final power to incur the Constitution
what he did is lay out the
the theoretical foundations for the
courts power and thence in subsequent
decisions Marshall put teeth you might
say in judicial review where he really
exercised power over acts of Congress so
it was a cumulative process building on
Marburg the longest serving chief
justice in history 34 years he surprised
somebody hasn't stayed longer than that
that is huge long very good thing just
think he was chief justice while I guess
there were five different presidents and
you know he belongs in the in the end of
the founding brothers he's always left
out that that always strikes me as
anomaly I mean here's the guy who was
there put the as in John Quincy Adams
said he put the Constitution on the
sound foundation that I'll push it rest
do you say that he wrote forty-nine
percent of the opinions when he was on
the side of the majority
during this thirty four years in a
constitutional cases he was all always
except in one case on the side of the
majority he only dissented in one
opinion of a constitutional nature
what's your next book I might do
something on the on the on the bird
treason trial wait that was the OJ
Simpson trial of the 19th century in
Richmond and John Marshall was the
presiding judge yes
we're out of time here is our guest
cover book by art Kent Mayer John
Marshall and the heroic age of the
Supreme Court thank you very much for
joining us thank you